hey what is up guys I'm kV HD here and
this is the HTC One m9 so last year we
had the HTC One m8 and that was a really
well built phone has some great fast
software and a let down camera and so
this year we have the one m9 which is a
really well boat phone as great fast
software and a let down camera so a
little background here I've been using
this one m9 as my daily driver on and
off since Mobile World Congress so a
couple of weeks now and yet I still kind
of have a little bit of trouble telling
a difference between it and the One m8
at least from the front without looking
at it for a little bit that's because
most of the changes with the one m9 are
on the inside and for HTC you've
probably heard this a thousand times
were people talking about this phone
it's a story of if it ain't broke don't
fix it and there was not a lot wrong
with the original one and eight so for
the n9 there's you know a couple of
small adjustments a couple of tweaks
here and there and some small changes to
make it better
so this HTC One m9 from the front and
the back is pretty similar looking to
the m8 it's an all metal phone again but
it's not unibody anymore so there's
actually several pieces of metal being
held together and along the sides you
get that strip all the way around the
phone that's a different color so on my
gunmetal m9 that strip is rounded off
and black but on the silver m9 that
strip is a new piece of metal so it's a
bit of a sharper edge and it's a gold
accent and the metal is also now this
brushed look and it's a little more
glossy kind of making it a fingerprint
magnet but also making it look a little
more like jewelry in a way so you got a
bit of a toss-up if you like that or not
it's definitely still a slippery phone
though so be warned
I haven't installed a skin on mine yet
but I'm pretty sure I'm going to end up
doing that just to make sure I never
drop it
HTC also moved of the power button from
the top right hand side to the right
hand side of the phone which is supposed
to be in a more natural easier to reach
spot for your thumb but unfortunately
that's where the volume buttons already
are so they put the power button
underneath those and I think that was a
bad move the power button is now too low
and to this day I still haven't gotten
used to it and it even if it's ridged
and clicky and separated from the rest I
constantly accidentally press the volume
down button like all the time
that they should have done is move the
volume buttons over to the left and had
that power button in a normal spot but
the good thing goes you still have
double tap to wake on the screen and you
can even put a sleep-wake toggle in a
software buttons if you want but yeah
overall build quality and button
placement was not broken so they had no
need to overhaul it to fix it
another thing that wasn't broken was the
display and the One m8 had one of the
best 1080p displays on any smartphone
last year and we're seeing more quad HD
displays this year from basically every
manufacturer but HTC is sticking with
their trusty 1080p and this LCD as much
as I like pixels is still great it's
very bright has great colors great
viewing angles and everything and since
it's still a 5-inch display the pixel
density is still excellent so you won't
be seeing any of the pixels from a
normal viewing distance and that awesome
display combined with the best speakers
in any smartphone make for an awesome
media experience whether you're gaming
or watching YouTube videos or whatever
you're doing boom sound is king and
second place isn't even close
now HTC did add this Dolby audio to the
m9 which is essentially just a software
toggle between two eq's music mode and
theater mode music mode is best for most
stuff I tend to leave it at that it's
not distorted at all and it gets super
loud and crispy and I love that a
theater mode is interesting because it
simulates a bit of a surround sound
effect so it can be cool for videos or
if you're watching a movie but it
definitely distorts it a lot more so the
build quality not broken the display not
broken the speakers definitely not
broken so onto the software and HTC has
kept it nice and clean with sense 7 on
this phone it's built on top of Android
5.0 - not sure when it's going to get
the 5.1 update but I'll keep an eye out
for that but this is now cleaned up to
be actually one of my favorite Android
skins that exists out there I still
prefer stock Android but I used to
really not like HTC Sense at all the
same way I hated TouchWiz and now there
are there still you know a couple parts
of it I don't like the keyboard for
example constantly infuriates me with
this terrible autocorrect I hate the
keyboard and the quick settings are
still pretty ugly to me I don't know why
I am is insist on skinning every little
part of Android and the quick settings
seems like the one I got away these just
get uglier all the time but aside from
stuff like that you know sense
seven is a really neat skin blinkfeed is
tidied up and of course still plugs into
your social feeds and gives you
up-to-date info and this is the first
HTC one where I didn't immediately want
to disable and remove blinkfeed
although you totally can and also
speaking of skins there's a whole theme
engine built into HTC Sense now so if
you really don't like the way it looks
stock there are a ton of skins to pick
from and apply that effect basically
everything about the software and the UI
from the launcher to the software
buttons to the app drawer and even the
quick settings so all the colors and all
the theme look will be changed and the
wallpaper too and you can grab one of
these pre-existing themes or you can
build your own theme from a wallpaper or
an image and that is a legit way to
customize your phone exactly as you want
it like a boss and also it's Android so
a lot of the other elements like the
keyboard or like the launcher you can
change those too if you don't like them
there were a lot of other neat tricks
built into this version of sense I liked
you can change the multitasking app view
to be either the cards which is what
we're used to in most other versions of
Android over the past few years or
grid-view
which is something that HTC sort of
introduced with the one series that not
everybody liked but now you have the
choice which is a cool way of not
exactly backtracking on that but I do
prefer the card view and you also have
these screen off gestures so we saw
these in the last one - you can not only
double tap to wake the phone and double
tap again to sleep but there are also a
bunch of other swipe Direction functions
that you can learn and decide to use and
actually enable individually if you want
to use them I found a lot of these were
just going off in my pocket with the
last HTC One but I did keep the
DoubleTap on because it didn't do that
in my pocket so that's pretty cool and
these also work very well with the dot
view case - so that's a pretty baller
combo and another thing they introduced
is this home screen widget it's supposed
to be a pretty smart thing where it
knows you if you're at home it knows
when you're at work it knows when you're
out all this is from your GPS location
and of course with every phone that's
tried to guess where I work it thinks my
school is where I work because I go
there every day but it worked okay give
me some decent productivity apps when I
went to class and then when I came home
and tried to get me to slack off and
watch YouTube you know the usual
constantly had these suggested apps too
that weren't even installed on my phone
not sure what that's about but yeah it
just moved off to the second homescreen
of mine and I just kind of left it there
to do its thing and I explore once in a
while but if you hated it more than I
did
you could easily remove it because it's
just a widget so yeah the software
experience here on the one m9 is great
overall performance to which I talk
about less and less in these reviews
because they keep getting so good now is
great three gigabytes of RAM Qualcomm
Snapdragon 810 that power that thing
it's basically a performance champ
you see me navigating through it it's
responsive animations are very short so
everything is snappy and quick and I
never really found an instance to get it
to stutter or hold up it did get warm
some people were asking if my m9 ever
overheated it did get warmer than other
phones I played with recently for sure
especially when charging or using with
the screen on for a very long period of
time but I never actually overheated
like I had with some other phones like
the g3 where it had you know limited
functionality because of the heat the
metal body this phone does get very warm
to the touch
when you're intensely gaming but
generally it's actually nothing to worry
about and the battery life has been
decent actually the one m9
it gives you a really detailed breakdown
of the battery usage in the software but
it doesn't actually give you a screen on
time so I felt like I was getting my
usual three to three-and-a-half maybe
four hours of screen on time but I
couldn't actually see a number at the
end of the day so I just go by the fact
that I was ending the day with 15 to 20
percent battery left to tell that it was
pretty good normal usage I had one weird
anomaly day where it died early but
overall battery life was pretty good now
undoubtedly the biggest challenge HTC
had when going from the One m8 to the m9
was the one part of the phone that
people did consider broke that's the
camera the HTC One m8 s biggest flaw
last year was its back facing four
megapixel or ultra pixel camera it was
actually a bit of a downgrade from the
m7 which had optical image stabilization
so that was the biggest change of
philosophy this time around as the one
m9 has a 20 megapixel camera so ultra
pixels are almost gone the front-facing
camera actually is still a pretty decent
ultra pixel selfie camera but now
everyone is curious just how good is the
slightly protruding 20
a pixel camera on the back of the m9
well it's still not that good and that's
unfortunate because we all like to take
pictures on our phones and normally it's
not a problem or anything but this one
is especially not good so 20 megapixels
yeah that's nice that's great and
everything pictures are sharper you have
more detail than before but the camera
here is a classic case of more
megapixels doesn't always equal better
pictures
the main problem here is dynamic range
so you know how you normally tap on the
viewfinder to set the brightness of your
photo
whatever you tap it on it changes the
auto exposure that's nice and quick and
snappy on this phone and it's taking a
picture is just as snappy too but it's
almost never exposed correctly to get
everything I want the dynamic range is
terrible on this camera and as a result
no matter how hard I try there's always
something way overexposed and blown out
or way underexposed and too in the dark
like every photo I take has this problem
so naturally I turn on HDR to try to get
some high dynamic range stuff but the
effect is kind of overly strong and
doesn't look natural anymore and all of
that combined with almost embarrassing
4k video that kind of looks like up
scaled 720p ah it's just a frustrating
cameraman and I wanted to be good so
much now look there's been talks there's
been talks about a software upgrade that
could potentially make this better and
usually that can happen but for this one
I'm thinking it's the hardware
I'm putting the blame on the hardware it
really shouldn't be this bad and if you
look it up most other high-end Android
smartphones even the iPhone use a Sony
sensor these things are tried-and-true
and produce some spectacular images for
some weird reason if Cece went with some
random Toshiba built sensor and that
would be where I place the blame it all
kind of makes sense the poor dynamic
range the washed out color even the best
image processing probably can't save
this one and I say that with regret
because like I said I wanted it to be a
lot better so overall as a package this
one m9 is still a really good phone and
for people coming from the 1m 7 the
first HTC One this is going to be an
awesome upgrade and for the one I made
probably less of a critical one
especially if you don't take a lot of
photos if you do take a lot of photos
long it's more
fawning are used to having a good camera
in your pocket this is sort of a hit or
miss thing again some of the photos it
takes can look pretty good but there are
better Android camera experiences out
there and the iPhone takes better
pictures and some windows phones take
better pictures so if you have cameras
and photo and video taking high on your
list of priorities when you're buying a
smartphone 109s probably not at the top
your list that being said like I said at
the beginning of this video this is an
extremely well-built phone with great
fast software and that's what it's doing
really really well here and it doesn't
hurt that it has the best speakers on
any phone period and also happens to
have a gorgeous 1080p display so that's
it for the one m9 if you enjoyed this
video review feel free to leave a thumbs
up below if you like that there's also a
subscribe button below if you want to
see more videos like this feel free to
tap that and I'll talk to you guys in
the next video
bass